[Music]  stranger things Gaytan matarazzo is  raising awareness about his very rare  genetic condition until claro cranial  dysplasia I was born with it its genetic  bone condition and it affects pretty  much everyone in the body specifically  the skull in the jaw and the clavicle  affecting one and a million people is  the reason why Gaytan doesn't have a  collar bone or adult teeth tomorrow on  the doctor's the fifteen-year-old  reveals how it was written into the show  it's called quite Oh cranial dysplasia  do the arm thing oh I was stretching in  the audition room like I was stretching  it was just he was like wait what you  just do so just say I started explaining  what it was that's why I was missing  teeth in the first season and I still  have my appliance and right now  [Music]  you  [Music]